[Applaudissements]
voici une salle de classe en 1950 qu'est
ce qu'on constate on constate de la
rigueur on constate de la discipline
à l'époque les professeurs appelé les
enseignants les élèves pardon par leur
nom de famille monnier rivalin aimons
les élèves viennent à l'école pour
acquérir des connaissances les pupitres
une trentaine a signé vers l'avant et le
professeur qui vient déverser son savoir
et ce modèle de classe en 1950 est
parfait est parfait pour ce qui les
attendent
qu'est ce qui les attend une économie
qui va bien qu est stable rien ne change
les travailleurs font toujours la même
chose
c'est répétitif et peu répétitif pardon
on est dans une production locale et ces
gens là vont faire un travail
pratiquement toute leur vie et voilà en
où en sommes nous sommes dans des
endroits le fun comparativement aux
usines de la photo précédente 5 à 7
jeudi soir party de noël
on est dans un nouveau mode de travail
on travaille en collaboration avec la
technologique est omniprésente et dans
certaines entreprises
j'ai même un avantage concurrentiel lui
uber alles bienne be n'existe poisson
technologies le mot d'ordre c'est
l'innovation parce que toute la
production
vous savez se fait en asie se fait à
l'extérieur les entreprises 19 port on
disparaît les technologies sont
omniprésentes et on est là pour résoudre
des problèmes complexes
la société change énormément et comment
on prépare ses supports personnes qui
vont travailler comme ça qu'est la
différence par rapport à la première
photo à part qu'elle est en couleur on
encore une trentaine de bureaux on
regarde en avant
le prof et la nomme déverser ses
connaissances auprès des jeunes âgés
sont de classe silence on apprend encore
ça dans les universités une bonne
gestion de classe et de sinon dans la
classe et technologies pratiquement
absents
de trois ordinateurs sur le côté quand
il marche avec un peu de chance on
prépare pour le secteur secondaire très
peu pour secte carrière vous êtes passé
je suis passé était dure pour moi
étaient divergents je posais des
questions
j'étais hyper actif et plus souvent à
l'extérieur dans la classe je dérangeais
quand je comprenais tour trop vite lâché
des blagues je m'en suis bien sorti fort
heureusement
alors je vous annonce que l'école doit
se réinventer monopole de la
connaissance les connaissances
actuellement sont dans les poches des
élèves
si les élèves ont deux heures de
transport pour venir à l'école pour
acquérir des connaissances qu'ils ont
dans leur poche
cherchez l'erreur on se pose des
questions pourquoi qui attend de
décrocheurs actuellement au québec mais
dans le monde également
actuellement vous allez beaucoup
d'étudiants qui ne vont plus à
l'université ils vont faire des mots qu
massive online cole 6 une douzaine de
mouk qui coûte 400 $ meilleures
universités au monde meilleur prof
les employeurs en disant voilà ce que
j'ai fait donnez moi une job je vous
montrer ce que j'ai fait si on ne change
pas le système éducatif
il part à sa perte nous entrons dans la
quatrième révolution industrielle celle
du numérique
et attention ça va frapper et ça va
travailler très fort j'ai regardé encore
une vidéo ce matin un robot qui
prenaient des feuilles de playground et
qu'il émettait sur le mur nous sommes
rendus là
l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle avoir un impact énorme dans
nos sociétés à l'époque c'était les
robots dans les usines mais actuellement
nous savons les algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle diagnostic
mieux les cancers de la peau des
dermatologues les radiologues c'est
pareil les avocats qui font de la
jurisprudence
ils vont perdre leur job les taxis et
transports on n'en parle même pas les
enjeux sont complexes
nous sommes dans une société qui va
excessivement vite regardez ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui est pensé ce qui va
arriver dans dix ans nous savons que la
moitié des gens ici qui ont un travail
vont le perdre
où va être complètement modifié deux
tiers actuellement des emplois que les
jeunes de mon école primaire vont faire
n'existe pas et les écoles doivent
préparer ces jeunes là comment à la
façon que je montre le début
cherchez l'erreur voilà ce qu'il faut
développer dans les écoles ces
compétences là ce qu'on appelle les 5 c
la collaboration il faut apprendre aux
jeunes à collaborer on ne peut plus
résoudre des problèmes seuls de notre
société
la communication habile à l'oral à
l'écrit dans différents contextes
je vois trop de personnes en entrevue
ont des supers cv et qui ne savent pas
se vendre il faut savoir se vendre la
pensée critique
allons-nous accepter que des robots
militaires tuent des humains est ce que
les jeunes savent ce qu'ils rentrent
dans leur fil facebook et instagram est
complètement filtré on y danse société
il faut développer la pensée critique
chez nos jeunes et ça presse nous devons
être complémentaire de l'intelligence
artificielle la compassion la gestion
des émotions les relations humaines il
faut la développer
on pourra pas concurrencer
l'intelligence artificielle sur son
terrain est la dernière et la plus
importante la créativité la créativité
la compétence du futur et la compétence
vital je les mentionnaient les enjeux
sont massifs
la production se fait à l'extérieur nous
devons inventer des produits et des
services dans notre société
alors qu'est ce que c'est que la
créativité y en a qui disent c'est inné
l'intelligence qui s'amusent einstein
disait se relier au biologique c'est la
capacité à trouver des solutions
originales à des problèmes à faire des
liens entre des choses qui n'existent
pas en partant avoir une attitude une
posture créative est ouvert d'esprit
écouter les idées des autres est
empathique steve jobs disait que la
créativité c'est faire des liens tissés
des liens entre eux on n'invente rien et
pour ça il ya un processus en quatre
phases la première chose la plus
importante
c'est la préparation développer la
curiosité chez les jeunes enfants
pour garnir sa bibliothèque interne de
connaissances tout de suite ne pas les
spécialiser faire des arts de la musique
la danse la science des sports d'où
l'importance dans les écoles d'avoir du
parascolaire pour ne pas venir juste
acquérir des connaissances développer
les cinq sens en faire des pôles immat
comme léonard de vinci qui était un
inventeur et et scientifique était
sculpteur saint-exupéry aviateurs
philosophe auteur la phase d'incubation
très difficile actuellement
on a deux minutes on accroche nous
téléphone pour regarder les nouvelles
pour envoyer un texto pour lui à nos
courriels nous laisser la chance de
laisser émerger l'idée le classer
clichés sous la douche en courant en
marchandant dans le parc dans la voiture
quand on n'écoute pas la radio à fond la
caisse
c'est prouvé chez les moines il fonde la
méditation que les ondes gamma augmente
donc plus de liens ne renouent donc faut
nous laisser le temps à me demander que
les idées émergent dans notre cégep à
sainte anne on a créé un programme
d'arlette des communications profil
science innovation et créativité on a
même pensé éléments et faire une période
de rien en une heure de la semaine ils
se fassent rien pas de techno pas de
crayon pas de feuilles
les gens viennent se déposer une heure
dans la semaine
enfin à face d'inspiration celle ci il
faut laisser venir
et quand il vient il faut la capter faut
pas tout c'est de passer à autre chose
prenez la note où il écrivait et ou pas
c'est votre jour est le plus difficile
mais c'est là que 95% des idées vont
disparaître l'innovation
quand vous avez une bonne idée faire en
sorte de la mener jusqu'au bout
ça prend du courage d'apprendre
d'énergie des processus des équipes pour
que l'idée de vienne innovation et
malheureusement on a 95 % de belles
idées qui sont actuellement nulle part
alors l'école est elle prête selon vous
à ce que je viens de vous dire
à l'école on travaille par silos maths
français anglais aucun lien entre les
matières comment voulez vous être
créatif alors qu on a dit que c'était ce
qui était multidisciplinaire qui était
important on a des standards des notes
des normes des règles d'admission ou de
réadmission on donne aux élèves des
problèmes donc il connaît ses solutions
ça sert à quoi on n'a pas de sens dans
les apprentissages qu'on leur donne on a
encore beaucoup dans le par coeur un
site web little words mentionne contre 2
5 ans les jeunes posent 300 questions
quand ils arrivent à l'école 20
questions
cherchez l'erreur quelles nouvelles
benson un spécialiste en éducation et en
créativité va même jusqu'à dire que
l'école actuellement tue la créativité
churchill falls est un cancre einstein
il a liberté
richard branson des décrocheurs eux ont
réussi
pensez à tous ceux qui sont actuellement
sur les bancs de la société qui n'ont
pas réussi des talents incroyables
créatifs parce que l'école ne s'est pas
adapté nous sommes dans une culture de
la note du cégep place le plus
d'étudiants dans les programmes
contingentés à l'université à quoi pense
un étudiant aucun déchet nous nos terres
côtières côté recruteurs pensez vous
qu'ils pensent à développer la
créativité la collaboration l'esprit
critique il a besoin sont 33 pour entre
endroit où 36 ou 37 pour entre médecine
on a un problème de norme
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait première
chose arrêtons le bourrage de crâne
développons des compétences et
compétences que j'ai mentionné tout à
l'heure plus de place aux processus plus
de place aux processus que vous souvenez
de vos notions de bio en première
secondaire il ya dix ans zéro
et si vous avez besoin en la poche la
connaissance
elle est dans la poche maintenant les
mettre les élèves en action pour qu'ils
résolvent des problèmes apprendre des
méthodes d'idéation des méthodes de
créativité chapeau de bono différentes
méthodes de brainstorming sas n'existe
pas de compliquer
faire de l'erreur un pilier dans
l'apprentissage à l'école on punit
l'erreur 0 en rouge alors qu'on le sait
maintenant l'expérience la somme de nos
erreurs y arriver il faut changer la
culture de nos écoles il faut que les
profs change le rôle
ce ne sont plus des passeurs de
connaissances plus maintenant c'est fini
dont les jeunes vont rester à la maison
ils doivent être des mentors les coaches
des motivateurs leur job c'est préparer
des problèmes en aval que les élèves
vont réseau dans l'équipe manière
créative des problèmes complexes pour
pas les sous-estimer les jeunes et pour
cela entre autres faut revoir nos
prisons pardon nos écoles lapsus prévu
actuellement nous écoles ressemblent à
des pénitenciers nos classes voulait vue
donc pas changé 36 bureaux 23 kg le prof
devant avec un peu de chance à un
tableau numérique
waouh il faut changer les classes il ya
plus d'avancé chez nous il ya plus
derrière eux un canon de chaque côté et
un écran de chaque côté le prof est au
milieu l'étape ce monde se baisse qui au
jeune apprend mieux debout pourquoi de
fil ce soir et des tabourets les tables
sont sur roulettes l'échéance ou
roulette
il faut des classes flexible en deux
minutes
vous devez pouvoir réorganiser votre
classe faut de la lumière faut que ce
soit le fun pour que ce soient éclairés
pour les jeunes puissent collaborer
c'est essentiel et pour faire ça ça te
rend du leadership audacieux
ça prend du leadership créatif faut pas
avoir peur de faire comprendre aux
enseignants qui sont allés à l'école qui
sont allés au cégep qui son université
et qui sont revenus à l'école qui ont
bien réussi à l'école parce qu'ils y
sont profs que la société voler les
emplois évolue quand les jeunes arrivent
marché du travail ouf on leur dit comme
d'habitude qu'est ce que tu as appris ta
cote r je m'en fiche
ce qui m'intéresse c'est est ce que tu
es créatif est ce que tu sais que
labouré par les langues de l'anc trois
langues
c'est ça qu'on leur demande et c'est ça
qu'on leur apprend pas investir dans la
formation
est-ce qu'on irait voir un dentiste qui
s'est pas formé pendant dix ans non on
envoie nos enfants dans les écoles alors
vous savez bien que l'éducation c'est
pas l'endroit où on forme le plus
cherchez l'erreur
ces jeunes là ce sont des élèves du
primaire de chez nous ils sortiront de
l'école dans une quinzaine ils vont
rentrer se mêle du travail on ne sait
pas quel emploi ils vont faire parce que
je voulais mentionner les deux tiers on
les connaît pas encore data scientist ya
deux ans personne ne savait ce que
c'était mais des comme ça là en pleuvoir
des problèmes va y en avoir des plus
complexes qu aujourd'hui surtout si on
les règle pas aujourd'hui on nous le dit
deux ans pour régler le problème dans
l'environnement faut faire la
décroissance ou bonne chance bonne
chance je pense que la solution ça va
trouver des innovations des machines qui
vont nous sortir du co2 pour remettre
dans la cour dans la terre ça existe
déjà même falloir trouver des idées et
pour sa flore est créatif
d'où l'importance de la développer à
l'école alors est-ce qu'on va enseigner
la créativité comme on enseigne les
maths et le français non mais on peut
enseigner les maths et le français en
développant la créativité et pour ça
soyons créatifs
merci
[Applaudissements]